oh my eye balls okay I'm done all right
hi hi everybody hey sorry I'm late oh
man it's been like crazy busy the past
few days so I'm trying to get everything
in order but I'm kind of in the middle
of doing 10,000 things at once and I'm
just lots and lots and lots of work to
do no time to do it in so hello
everybody yes hi hi hi hi I know I know
I know I know sorry also the color is
off on my camera my camera's been acting
funny like for the past few days like
the auto color it doesn't like me
anymore so I don't know what's going on
there I'm like a little orange I don't
know why I've tried to do it manually
but I'm not as beautiful as I normally
am and I'm
normally I'm normally extremely
beautiful but today I'm
not okay hello yes yeah my stepmom's
fine don't worry about that yeah she's
fine don't worry about it um they're
just keeping her at the hospital for the
few days but I'd rather not talk about
it considering it's kind of personal so
um the re if you didn't know the reason
I wasn't here yesterday is because my
mom is in the my stepmom is in the
hospital um for personal reasons don't
ask why but she's going to be okay so
anyway how youall doing how youall
doing hi hello from this Home State Ohio
there's nothing good about Ohio except
maybe Drew
Carrey can you touch my chin
I don't know no let let's go ahead and
say no no on that one see hello from the
East Coast Canada a
sorry let's get the insulting right out
of the gate like boost bursting open as
soon as the live stream and start
insulting random people start with
Canada the ice box in yoser and yeah
with three men in a Ben at Holy yeah
okay all right is that good that good
for everyone all right good all right
good Canada checked off the list made
fun of Canada done who's next who's up
next who's up next who wants some huh
who wants some okay all
right yeah yeah yeah hi hi hi hi hi I
know I know things are going crazy
anyway we're going to get right into it
because I've got like no time today uh
today my brother is getting a giant
shipment of books like 50,000 and that's
not even an exaggeration it's like
50,000 books he's getting today and I
got to help him with that so I'm like on
a Time press I had to meet with Wade
before this I had to run over and meet
Wade stop by the store hit the hit the
post office come back here I woke up at
like 6:00 this morning I went to bed
like 1 last night I'm I'm running on
like no sleep so let's
go as I slowly get up and me oh wait
hang on wait no wait where's the I need
a soundtrack to my life here there we go
okay music's playing oh my back hurts
and oh my life is such
pain you like my
shirt someone gave this to me it's nice
huh
okay
youel just like
me oh
oh all right then
okay all
right some yeah yeah wearing Grandma
underwear
today oh let's open it bubble
wrap
oh okay that's so
much oh there
that o what have we got here look at
this it's a oh God it's a money
jar what I don't know
why oh live the Live stream's acting
kind of funny don't know why my
internet's been acting up hopefully it
doesn't go bad I I don't know oh there's
something else it's not a coin jar
though it's a ooh it's even better than
a coin
jar it's even
better it's like it's like 10 times as
better as in a coin
jar hang
on hang
on tightly wrapped in here hang on it's
a bottle of derero
M I'm going to use this I going to use
this thank you very much but anyway
can't drinking is bad until you turn 21
and then it becomes very
good that'll do it that'll teach the
kids
oh o my back let's see who that was from
also there woo look at this this look at
this look at that look at
that that's more like it that's better
actually so that's really well done
thank you I got a whole collection of
beart over here I uh oh no oh no I'll
have to glue that back
on okay sorry if that was loud I got
this here I'll have to glue that back on
later somehow it popped off just little
Glu up I got a whole bunch of stuff over
here I'm not going to get it
though ah thank you sorry sorry I'm
quite loud I turned my uh microphone
volume up because people said I was a
little quiet last time so this time I'm
trying to be a little better also in
case you didn't know I'm kind of tired
so I'm going to act a little
loopy just saying that right now I'm
going to be weird and there's not a
thing I can do about it cuz that's what
happens when I get
tired
is that a boob no that's Mario Mario and
Ouija Mario and Ouiji it's upside down
but I don't
care and also some beef jerky thank you
I like beef
jerky who is this from this was from
Jessica Mason Jessica Mason thank you so
much for the derero and everything else
and yes sorry if the live stream is
being a little
choppy I don't know why it it just does
sometimes right like my internet has
been really really bad lately I don't
know why my upload was going slow today
I'm going to have to call uh my internet
provider and get them so if it's shoppy
for you I'm sorry I
apologize done all done thanks for
coming to today's mail
video
huh okay I'm up don't worry about me I'm
alive oh my back I'm so
old all right suck it up Markiplier all
right this is from Matthews Moore m o Mo
s please read me
all right all right F by me hey Mark
please read me I came a long way from
Germany before you go for your presence
I have a few words to say my name is
matthus Moore 26-year-old huge F Germany
first of all thank you for being such a
great guy every day when I get home from
work the first thing to do is to check
YouTube if there's anything new from you
watching your videos always cheers me up
no matter how bad the day is I haven't
missed a single one you since you played
slender the8 pages with which was also
the first video I ever saw from you but
my personal favorite has to be the bear
driving simulator 2000 yes that game was
amazing I almost cried from laughing
while watching it my wife really hates
you for shouting so much in front of the
camera it's quite amusing for me though
she always calls you
a which means something like noisy
Braton German so it would be amazing if
you could get a shout out to her her
name is Rebecca well I'm not a noisy wow
actually that's that that's a pretty app
description of who I am on YouTube so
that's pretty fitting I'm a gamer for
many years now and also passionate video
game collector so for your main present
I want to give you one of the in my
opinion best video game systems ever
made along with some pretty special
games I hope you like them also got a
load of German candy uh sweets in the
front of the camera for my person oh I
want you to read the name of the suite
okay all right then there's some
suggestions down here but thank you
matthus let's see what you
got
oo it's choco BNS I love when I when I
get home from work and I'm Tasty for I'm
hungry I'm hanging for a treat I grab
for some delicious choco bonss choko
bonss it's the tasty treat that can't be
beat you eat it with your feet and then
you eat then you wash it down with a
beet then you I don't
know all right and
then
tofi when I can't pronounce tofe
correctly I call it tofi cuz I'm a [__]
no I'm just kidding
tofi shil Goods stacked in
tofy combination D Jaden get
sm de be
toffey it's good for you
is this is not going well
milka I got nothing that
one there Oreo flavored there's some
crushed candy eggs here there's a lot of
stuff what is this this is a bomb oh
it's a
something it's a ooh
interesting look at this it's um the
case covers for these games Warf stash
the game a lot of work went into this
one good do M
her oh these These are um these are
Nintendo Game Boy games so man I mean I
mean these aren't all these games it's
just cleverly done so I'm guessing the
system in here is oh here's another one
oh harabo we have harabo bears
let's see I've eaten har bow a
lot check it out
uning wow it's a black Game Boy check
that out I I haven't had a Game Boy
since I lost it in an airport when I was
when I was flying over to Korea I I
don't even remember when but I was a
little kid so it's been a long time
since I had a Game Boy so thank you so
much I know this probably has a lot of
history to it so uh thank you so much
like all I I'll get to chat in a second
here I'm trying to do 10 things at once
and my brain is really frazzled right
now so I can't quite focus on anything
what please read please read please read
please read please read please read
please read please I read it okay let's
see the music changes you like you stick
with the music the music
stays and it's
changing huh I'm tired
I said before if you're new just joining
us I'm very tired so I'm going to be
very weird today oh not the T
Fe okay
anyway next
oh what is going on in my brain oh what
is this we got some oh I played Mario in
Luigi this is Mario and Luigi for the DS
but not the most I played the first one
and it was pretty good I liked it a lot
also we got rock band here um I don't
have any of the peripherals but I mean
that's pretty cool and then
there's Xbox Live arcade and then Banjo
and Kazooie so a bunch of uh a bunch of
games here so thanks for that and
there's a note this is from Joseph
Anderson by the byy in case you were
curious please read this I'm Brazilian
and like Markiplier I read it done
winner see best YouTube player ever no
not even close I am so unskilled when it
comes to playing games on YouTube it's
you know part of it has to do with
trying to talk and play at the same time
time but another part has to do with I'm
not that great at video games apparently
like I'm pretty good to some then again
I don't practice a lot of them
religiously but anyway I need to get to
this note oh
yeah all right what do we got
here we love you when you're weird we
still love you when you're not banjo and
Kaz oh my
goodness hello Mark my name is Joseph
don't mind my handwriting you are the
best person
ever uh I would subscribe subscribe to
every video but TT I have an Xbox 360 so
I can't poof I wish I could meet you in
person I started watching your videos
when Slender entered my head sometimes I
can't breathe while watching you that
doesn't sound good please make more
Slender videos well I'll see you in the
next letter
bye-bye and then there's a drawing you
can't see it cuz it's washed out but
kind of a kind of a kind of a drawing
there sorry my lighting is all weird
today I don't really know let's
see people talking about Wade in my live
stream it's more likely than you think
thank you so much I really do appreciate
that Joseph I've gotten a lot of Xbox
games and and I don't even have my Xbox
in my new apartment I probably got to
get that sometime
soon oh there's Wade oh why is Wade here
Wade oh
it's C creative it's a box with a letter
in it very creative I'm obligated to
read it
now oh you taped
it you made your letter hard enough to
open all right there we go all right
what do we got here o
what what I got a a totally real $3 bill
which is awesome I
guess cool thanks all right dear marbl
you make my day every time I watch your
videos I wanted to say that I Lov
watching your random horror compilation
videos because it makes me laugh my
father has cancer and I will try to
donate some money in your charity videos
I would really like to play with you you
via computer on Steam if you want to add
cotton ey Joe I hope you have Gary's Mod
Counter Strike so we have a chance to
play game on bro Michael Burrows you are
a boss I apologize but I don't accept
anyone as a friend on Steam unless I
work with you but I really do appreciate
the letter and I'm glad that you you
really like my video so thank you so
much waight is better than you well at
least it when it comes to drinking
anyway I'll admit that I'm not very good
at
drinking I don't even know what that
means I have a low tolerance for alcohol
it's part of my genetic
programming SC marbot Mark bot is here
again Mark bot will destroy all Mark bot
Must
Destroy Mark but
okay
next all right all right
it was Mark markb is went away markb
went
away oh what is this I'm the ground here
go
away what do we
got dear Mark I just want to say thank
you for all the smiles you bring to my
face on the days I need them most for
all the money you donate to charity so I
just I got you just a little something
even though I it would never be enough
because of all you've done for us
congrats on 300,000 Subs your fan
Elizabeth's stress ball for Surgeon
Simulator oh good goody it's a Pac-Man
stress ball actually that's really cool
if I could get it out quickly I would
test it right now but that's that's
really cool I like that
wa damn you patient I'm a doctor from
Nicaragua how dare you do this to me I
turned I don't know what I was doing
there and there's
also a predicta
pen I have to ask wait I have to ask it
a question and it will answer oh Magic
predicta
Pen what do I
ask what do I ask the predicta
pen oh Magic predictor pen do you tell
the right answers
dude no
way well then are you even useful a
little
bit not for a million
dollar why don't you go die in a fire if
you're always as much
help hell yeah this useful I mean
useless the thing's useless is useless
it even agrees that it's useless what
the hell all right
whatever
look at this
thing it's a Domo thingy it's a Domo
thingy mustaches are
undercover if you know what I
mean
yeah must
okay okay sound like a high
goat n man
I'm my jokes are pretty bad today get
ready get ready everybody my jokes are
off the wall
today oh God what am I doing with my
life H oh the reason um it's on a
Tuesday and not a Monday is because
yesterday I was visiting my stepmom in
the hospital she's fine don't
ask okay
who's this from who are you
carolan
holos
okay do not give away anything including
the pony Apple Jack or the hand
sanitizer and mints are a good
snack read letter first I don't see a
letter oh here's a
letter you have the best invisible
mustache
to markar Happy Valentine's Day you're a
little late but that's okay I forgive
you follow the
sun was what does that have to do with
the
sun it's another My Little Pony thing so
I don't understand but follow the sun
Valentine okay cool
dear marip I'm a huge fan and I love
your videos you make me laugh I lost my
father when I was 18 and I know how
hard I know you're not a brony I'm
really sorry for your loss but it
literally just ends abruptly there it's
I know how hard and then end so I'm not
making fun of it at all I know you're
not a brony but I bet you would like a
valentine even though it's a little late
comes with a temporary tattoo I don't
see a temporary tattoo but I will try to
look for it later I hope you read this
but if not I understand you get a lot of
fan mail Mark you haven't make me laugh
when I feel depressed my friends like
you and keep the videos coming in the
Box are some things I have for you
slendy loved you sincerely a fan carolan
harlo oh harlo that makes a lot more
sense than w
w
okay
hi michella Mich
Michaela Michaela from
Washington
hi all right what do we got in here we
got a bag of little not edible Peeps and
Angry Bird thingies bird thingies
and we got a bot bottle of hand
sanitizer cool and a bottle
of antibacterial hand
lotion why but thank you I guess thank
you very
much you know when it says kills 99.9%
of germs that's actually a lot it kills
statistically uh more closer to 40 to
60% but these are done in a very strict
lab condition um so when what they do is
they take a petri dish with germs in it
and they literally squirt coat it in
completely with whatever this is and
then they count like oh 99.9% of died
but if you put it on your hands it's
only like 40 to 60% die uh fun fact for
the day
Tada the more you
know okay all right well we got two
boxes we got a two for
one all
right what does this
say set a who who what is what is what
do that what does that say I can't tell
huh I don't know but it says two pro
your fan Williams okie dokie
is that some sort of gang sign
Markiplier is not affiliated with any
gangs there's also a shot glass in here
but it's it's extremely tightly wrapped
I will get that later but you can see
there's like a little dagger design on
it so thank you guys so much I just
realized when I did this someone's going
to someone's going to Loop a gif of me
doing this so here you go here's more
ammo there you
go
what is going on in my brain I have no
please read on camera you're welcome
glad to help you there oh there's
more
ah all right dear marbler I have been
watching your videos since February at
the time I like to oh February of
2012 well I wasn't around in February of
2012 but man you have got to be the
earliest fan ever if that's the case
probably 2013 is what they mean at the
time I like to watch cood videos and
slender I watched PewDiePie play Slender
but I didn't really like them the next
day in my recommended videos there was a
video called Slender Christmas Special
by Markiplier I watched it and I loved
it and after I watch your
videos and that's it at the time you had
9,000 Subs you are my favorite YouTuber
second is Tobuscus sincerely Tyler I
hope you like my drawing which is this
one oh man stupid glare you guys it's
sorry it's hard for you to see but there
we go okay that's better nothing beats
the stash and I actually uh in case you
guys didn't know uh PewDiePie is
actually a really nice guy I've gotten
you know he's he's really nice and I got
nothing against the guy so I mean you're
entitled to know your own thing but just
know if you don't like his videos know
that he's a really nice guy so anyway
that's all I have to say about this
all right and what else do we have in
here we have
Jello what is
this what is that pasta shapes and
tomato sauce what is that like ravioli I
have no idea except with Scooby-Doo and
Cheese Nips now cheesier
tasting when you don't have access to
cheese it's why not grab Cheese
Nips there's a joke in there somewhere I
I just can't my brain can't put two and
two together so
anyway thank you so much like I said
before my brain is like not working
today cuz I'm very
tired and then I had to see Wade today
so that like drained everything out of
me you know all my patience it took to
deal with Wade and just be in the same
room and as him is just like drained me
out I'm done I'm clocked out I am gone
mentally cuz just the physical and
mental torment that being in the same
room with him takes on you is awful is
he still here this isn't as funny if
he's not here is he still here wait
sucks
wa my back I'm
SK dude wait I called you you at 12:45
in the afternoon that was your wakeup
call what wrong with
you any wait oh anyways I will see you
in the next video market player Holy
balls a
poof a
poof a poof poof wait a a
poof like magic a
poof someone make a gift of that do it
one more time for a poof that wasn't as
good use the other ones got you three
there can do I mean this is going to be
Gable moments I'm just going to do Gable
things and you guys can make them into
gifts so do what you will with all of
those all right oh no this poor dog it's
growing a mustache of some sort look at
it look at the little poochie with the
damn light look at her little bie with
the mustache looks like tusks pink
tusks okay all right I'm not dead I was
acting I was acting
acting put that there put that down
there all right terf
dear marbler I wrote a letter two mail
episodes ago you probably don't remember
though anyway anywh who I would love to
say that you are awesome more awesome
and cute oh thank you I have been
subscribed to you for maybe three or two
months ago I remember my first video of
you was Slender The Nine Pages I laughed
my flipping butt off I was looking for
shenan shenan oh shenan I know shenan
slender best day ever
anywh who I'm your biggest fan the
background of my iPad is your
picture and I have a this is really hard
to read by the way I'm I'm trying my
best here I have a t-shirt that is just
like yours but says
marra marra and it's got a bow on the m
i could go on forever anyways I wish I
could meet
you you meet you can hug you I bet you
have heard this a lot but you get to
hear it again in the Box I sent you
cookies and dud of SpongeBob and a
little LST pet shop and the glasses are
I'm really not trying to screw this up
it's really hard to read um or a little
gift from Wisconsin and it would be cool
if you could send me an email it's all
right if you can't I understand well I
will you in the next video I will you in
the next video bye-bye
love Ariana Cloud joke on
back my number is in your dreams LOL say
hi to Yummy for me
please you're welcome yummy I know you
watch everything I do
so Ariana Ariana e ar Ariana Ariana you
want some
Ariana huh yeah oh
yeah all right okay all right what else
is in here
ooh go my favorite sports team go go do
good beat the opponents
soundly it scored a goal unit
basket this is for like Wisconsin or
something right the cheese heads I think
that's a thing I have no idea
I don't really know isn't cheese had a
thing if I'm if it's not a thing I'm
going to like oh look at that it's a
little pencil topper wait no it's not
it's a something or other but it's a
little
fish there's something else in
here
oh that's what you meant oh okay it was
a DVD not dud DVD of SpongeBob okay
thank you so I haven't watched SpongeBob
in forever I think they've just put it
on Netflix or something I might have to
catch up on some old episodes catch up
on my childhood you know know what I'm
saying y'all know what I'm saying yeah I
thought so yeah so okay all right
next oh my back I'm so
old I'm so old all right oh
man what are my computer spec
maybe I'll send you an extra GPU that I
have and don't need I doubt it you don't
need to do that my computer's pretty
good it's a dual scram jet injected
induction cooling system with a Geral
wheel it's pretty good I mean I don't
want to
brag built it
myself got all the materials out of this
green earth look it's a
camel oh not I got not this time you
won't get me this time animal I
enough with the acting I'm an
actor all right what do we got here dear
Markiplier we are going to get you so
fat love your devoted fan
Leslie well thank you Leslie what did
you get me oh my god
oh I know exactly what these
are my mom used to get me these for
these all the time they're
um they're shrimp
flavored like cracker chips I don't know
how to describe them at first you know
when we first got them I really liked
them and then I started to really
dislike them but I'll try it again I'll
see if it's it's good and by the way my
brother tried the the Tostitos or the
takitos or one of those spicy chips that
were sent to me in another one he really
like those so if we could figure out
where to get them and we also got some
candies I'm so shut up oh it's my mom I
thought that was way sorry Mom sorry
didn't mean to yell at you I'm sorry
okay and then we got dried mangoes there
we go Takis Takis that's it
Takis those Takis don't know how to get
them what would you do if all your fans
turned against you I would run really
fast I would fight him off with my crazy
ninja Monkey Style
hota Hey look
Wade's douche screw you Wade I'm doing a
mail video I'm doing a mail video
Siri I'm doing a mail video a mail video
get off my back I hate you
Wade
processing
it said Siri thought I said I'm okay how
are
you what I I'll send
it I'm not joking that's what it said
why
why somehow Wade made that
happen somehow
all
right what's a hug hug hug hug h
w w Mark but his
Bat
Wade says great thanks for taking the
time to care about my
feelings shut up Wade I hate you so much
why don't you go die in a fire I want
you to die I hope you go
to
processing is it going is it
going is what
going Wade is it going is it is it going
waade is it I don't know please read
first greetings from inota the wine is
local and very good unra toall carefully
Al the enjoy the funny postcards shot
glass and handmade towel love what you
do from Minnesota e Minnesota checked
off the list made fun of Minnesota in
case you missed it I made fun of Canada
earlier so thank you so much there's
apparently a bottle of wine in here H oh
yeah and a handmade towel apparently I
didn't even know you could make hand
make a
towel well I mean of course you can hand
make a towel but I mean I don't know
what tools you would use to do it
oo ah Indian Island Winery a dream
catcher Minnesota semisweet red table
wine what type of red is
it it doesn't say it's just you
know red red table one okay got it thank
you and also some postcards from
Minnesota
e oh sis you're from Min signs you're
from Minnesota the weather is usually
80% of your conversation when you say
down south you're referring to Iowa
going Swedish no tires come Stander on
your car Perkins was the only hang out
op in high school do it to them when
they say safe people know talking about
nor town
okay my Minnesota accent went kind of
crazy there I apologize for
nothing the number of bars in church
okay I'll read those later it's a it's a
I shouldn't read those on camera un bad
oo wow it's a shot glass that has
different lines half o to 4 oz that's
pretty awesome not bad all right a 4 o
shot glass
cool this my I've never I've never had a
shot glass I think so thank you oh my
gosh that's a lot of
text apologies but I will not be able to
read that cuz it's already gone posting
essays on Twitch is not how you get your
story R I'm I'm I'm really sorry but
it's not okay let's keep moving
forward what we have please read on
camera dear Markiplier my name is
Stephanie and I have been watching your
videos for 5 months now I've been going
through some hard times lately and your
videos along with the help of friends
and family have kept me mostly out of
the dark and from making some fatal
decisions I watch your videos at least
once a day and I've kept up with all
your mail videos I did some fan art that
I hope you like I know you're not a
brony but I just had to draw you as
Market Pony I used bases to draw them
because sadly I am artistically
challenged LOL I know you are always
complaining that you are so fat but I
sent candy too there are also a couple
more surprises inside I hope you like
everything thanks for being so awesome
keep up the good videos your fan
Stephanie so thank you for that I am not
a brony
but I I won't stop the creative people
from doing what they
do a shot glass of some sort I think it
says let let bet let let let's
bet
oh let's Bola go good good lesson live
by also another one come at me
bro come at me
bro what's up what's up huh what's up
not looking at the camera what's up huh
what's up huh what's
up o I love runs look I got runs I love
runs oh they're
close I
like except for the banana everyone
hates the banana runs but yet they keep
putting them in there it's like the sad
prize you know got a bunch of prizes
that you could win and then you get a
really sad one when you get banana
and good grape grape grape is best of
course but red good green good orange
also good but banana who likes
banana
no no one likes bananas if you like
bananas you're likely a communist
communist communist like banana flavored
ruts trust me mar I'm totally not a
drunk and loser I'm totally not drinking
my
life damn
commies damn
it I'm the best YouTuber
ever PewDiePie is docus a they
talentless
h
I almost choked on a
run hold
on
processing almost died there almost died
but I held it
together
H WTF is wrong with this guy so many
things so many things are wrong with me
don't even ask that's some fan
art there's me as the Pony as was
described a slendy
Pony
Pander
slend I'm not
sure and then normal slendy with the
mustache thank you thank you thank you
so much I'll put that safely back in
there when is your next charity live
stream um probably next weekend I'm
thinking next weekend sometime and not
this
weekend next
one next I believe so don't quote me on
that cuz Wade's going out of town to see
his
girlfriend I think that's it thank
you wait didn't text me back he didn't H
he didn't tell me if it was going is it
going Wade Wade is it going wait is it
going is it going I don't know if it's
going or coming I don't know is it
going is it
going like I said this is going to be a
weirder live stream stream I'm very
tired what do we got
here let's
see dear Marly my fiance and I have been
watching your videos for a long time and
we think you're awesome he's been
watching since you were 50,000 and then
shared your videos with me oh you're a
girl or maybe not Heather and Rob okay
you're a girl it's inspiring to see
someone making a difference in the world
doing something they love all right I'm
not doing that your videos are
entertaining to watch and you have a
great personality so we decided we
wanted to get you some gifts to show our
appreciation and make your day brighter
if only by a little bit we hope you
enjoy them from Heather and Rob keep up
the great work also do a let's play of
Silent Hill I will
gosh thank you all right let's see
what's in
here tissue
paper there's a letter some
sort
oh okay it's a uh it's a wedding
invitation I don't think I'll be able to
go but thank you nonetheless if anyone
else wants to join
you and let's see
here there is a
flower Little Flower there is
a mini radio controlled Yoshi card how
cool is that not bad all about the you
Mario Kart we not
bad my girly voice is similar to Mickey
Mouse is it is it really similar to
Mickey Mouse or is it Sultry and sexy
and doesn't make you
confused or does it sound like that old
man from Family Guy
oh get that fat ass back over here oh
okay
all
right thank
you and also a Yoshi
keychain Herbert is that his name
Herbert the Pervert of course of course
it
is Herbert the
Pervert
o well look at that that is so cool it's
a
mouse with a mustache on it how cool
cool is that how did you get that on
there I don't even know well done though
man that's so cool well done I'm
impressed oh man there's something else
in here
too FR FR
fragile fragile
frog French wait here it is again what
is what is that word
fragil
fragile fragile
frag fra G fry gay that doesn't sound
right this really taped up so I'm going
to open this no it's it's like really
really ridiculously taped up here so I
don't know what it is but I will open
this later you can rest
assured thank you so much
though yeah I'm surprised how how many
people don't know the reference that I'm
doing when I don't when I pretend not to
know what fragile means no one knows
Christmas Story the lamp no
one let's see
now what do we have here oh it's uh it's
a cash cow it's a cash cow it's a
cow made of cash someone said this guy
is insane this guy is insane yeah I know
I'm crazy crazy
psycho oh that's not a
letter someone gave me a football card I
think I didn't even know they made
football cards much like baseball cards
it's kind of cool I guess also got
another sticker on the back of I don't
know who this is but I probably should
considering he's in the
Bengals wait who's Dan Haron Dan
Heron wait who is this is this someone I
should
know also who's Lance
Briggs
wait no he's not from Ohio State he's
from the
Bengals I don't know who this guy's from
it's a
c
uh he's a linebacker who's this I know
this from the
Bengals Chicago Bears oh okay well how
was I supposed to know
that all right there's no letters here
it's all
blank put this over
here the bears oh I remember the Bears
from that SNL get duh Bears we're
looking at a guaranteed three p maybe
even a four
P bears bear bears
bears don't pound on your chest it's bad
for you okay we got zombie playing cards
but there doesn't seem to be playing
cards in here there seems to be
Kool-Aid Kool-Aid also crystal meth oh
yeah sugar cubes oh sorry I always get
those two confused there sugar cubes and
Kool-Aid I can make me some
Kool-Aid all right I like me some
Kool-Aid also some there's a a warhead
sour on there don't drink the
Kool-Aid you know fun fact no this is a
totally madeup fact but you'll all
believe me
anyway after that incident where um the
the mass suicide at that cult um there
was a lot of Kool-Aid at the location
and to try to downplay it Kool-Aid the
company tried to say no no it was all
flavorade Kool-Aid wasn't really there
but it was majority Kool-Aid so this
this is where the totally made up fact
comes in they created the Kool-Aid man
as a response to that to try to put a
happy face back on their thing no that's
it's a total lie it's total lie total
lie all right what is
this is this Crystal math there's some
writing on the bag but it's faded
out it's a bomb it's the bomb there's
also word puzzle
and
maripur
marer so thank you so much I don't know
who this is from
though um Perry it's from Perry so thank
you Perry thank you so
much it's meth someone peed on yeah
that's it that sounds about all
right all
right that's how I cough don't make fun
of me we got something from Amazon here
and we got a little
later let's see dear Mark Amazon makes
me keep this short but I just have to
say your videos make me happy when times
are bad from Jack Missouri that's his
real name by the waye so let's see what
he got
take that off of there wait oh yeah I
already read
that get that off of
there get that off Amazon does a nice
job on wrapping presents I mean I don't
know who does it but probably done by
machine but still it's pretty
good very very
cool dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign
dollar sign $6
a
oh it's St straws they're star straws oh
oh okay thank you so much for these stat
draws Jack Missouri if that is your real
name all
right getting my second one when I feel
all warm and fuzzy inside okie
dokie hey Mark I hope this makes it in
time for the last three videos just a
quick quickie congrats on all your
success we love you now to the Box these
instructions must be followed in this
exact order you must not look into the
bottom of the
Box until everything inside has been
seen and made fun of there is a super
ultra mega super prize at the bottom of
the box that must not be seen until
everything inside has been seen your
friend and loyal mature fan girl
Victoria L Falkner AKA Tor PS slendy did
not appreciate the statue made on
Minecraft and also please P play the
Amnesia CM story of the small horse P.S
you're welcome okie dokie thank you
there's a used
tissue let's see there's some b art of
an M for the Markiplier logo thank you
so much there's a voodoo doll of me
pinch him on the butt oh that was
probably the stupidest thing I've ever
done but everyone else like it poke him
he really ow
oh stab the dragon stab the dragon
you're getting hit in the
back anyone this going to seem weird if
you don't know what I'm talking about
stab the
Dragon no okay all right
no all right there's a whole bunch of
things in here but I got to I got to see
there some fan
art there's a bunch of stuff here so I
gotta get through quickly there's some
more fan art of the whole Horror family
thank you so much oh that's Wade too all
right cool and let's see bet some more
fan art of me on a rocket ship going
around the earth for some Kerbal action
nice and some more fan art let's see
it's me trying to hide from Cen
thank you so
much I actually missed if anyone
actually commented on me stabbing Dragon
so it's it's already gone by so I have
anyone did I didn't see it so sorry then
it's me being drunk making fun of sendy
and his stupid statue in
Minecraft let's see and then there is
some more fan art there's a lot of fan
art in this one so sorry it's so stupid
light is really bright thank you let's
see and then some more fan art and let's
see what that was at the bottom of this
besides the used tissues it's a troll
face you're welcome okay good for you
good for you good for you where's my pen
where's my
pen here's my
pen that's not my pen where' my pen Go
where' My Magic Pen go
sto my all right
what thank
you too far away too far
away all
right let's see what we
get oh you're going to have a lot of
trash today tell you that it's a
highlighter flower a Squidward thing oh
it's a Squidward pen this would be very
awkward to write
with happy birds oh no Angry Birds Happy
Wheels Angry
Birds I think that's bubble that's
almost coming off so I just kept that
Warf stash
bits and a
note
bom dear Mark hope you enjoy the stuff
in the box and if you want you can give
it away or keep
your fan Alex thank you so much Alex
you're the bomb haha suck it cigo haha
son stuck like syo you think you're
better than
me I shall see you in hell
syo and then another package from Amazon
uh-oh it's a box within a box what we
got where'd my knife
go who's taking my
stuff who taking my stuff man where's my
knife who took my stuff Wade God damn it
Wade damn it all the hell
Wade Wade what are you
doing
Wade
Wade what the hell Wade where's my knife
what where's my
knife use a
pencil yeah I'm so badass I open a box
with a
pencil where are you least expect it to
be that doesn't make any sense Wade a
Wade you're so dumb makes sense what is
this what is
this
oh
what happened what happened everybody
what happened I feel so
strange
okay
I'm just wa I was watching I was
watching me I'm so I'm so funny I'm so
funny look at me go
okay all right thank you for the chicken
head I don't know who that was though
there wasn't really anything else in the
box so thank you all
right oh there's oh waade come on jeez
Wade come on stop hiding my stuff
Wade oh it's a bigon it's a big it's a
biging what's in here I don't
know I no no it's a
big
something it's a sword kind of hang
on wait hang on whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa this is
from Jane
Ferris my name is Jane that's Jane with
a silent y why would it be J what
J I'm 19 and I live in a city near
Chicago I wanted to give you a little
something for Giggles you're the best
person on the planet thank
you hang onbody hold your
horses everybody hold your
horses whoa
ha is I ye Nave super nerd
ha okay enough SW
gra those are
disorienting there's also one more thing
in here wedding photo photo
props props for wedding photo we might
just use
this and then oh it's my oh if anyone
was curious this is the warf sash
mustache this is exactly the warf stash
mustache this is the one I just bought
again uh for no
reason this is it it's called Uh it
doesn't really have a company on it
costumes USA is the company
costumes
USA or death
my that's the one thank you
everybody
right I am tired tired tired tired I'm
tired I'm tired oh I'm
tired we shall press on for we have more
stuff
here I am still
wrong hi from England hi
hi hi I have Silent Hill too no need to
send it to me we have a
shirt not a [__] a
shirt I'd love to stay in chat but I
really must Dash
mustash I'd love to stay in chat but I
really must
Dash thank
you thank
you that is um that is a pun that's a
pun not a good pun but it's a pun
nonetheless no thank you for that who is
that
from doesn't say
all
right did everyone enjoy the
show hang on trying to open
this oh boy
who almost through almost through oh
that didn't open it at all there we go
ooh mustache ice tray ha
awesome dear Mark I will keep this short
since I know that there are many other
fan mail that you have to go through
I've been meaning to send you fan mail
for a long time but recent events have
kept me from doing so I was not
physically affected but I was still
connected it was difficult to deal with
everything that was happening but this
is what makes your videos important with
each day your videos make things a
little brighter and for that I thank you
enjoy the ice cube tray and clips and
keep up the good work Boston Strong
Carolyn
Chan so thank you for
that and thank you for the
clip nice cool like little like I like
this I like I want a candy I see
candy I eye candy Oh eye candy okay and
then a mustache so thank you for that
that's really cool all right let's just
do one more push through one more we're
enjoying the show
all right let's
do from Holly Becker Holly
Becker
okay all right
ter what the whoa this really is a
voodoo doll of
me
this is going to work great for monster
puppet pals when that becomes a series
it become
series let's get all the gang together
where's every it's buried under so much
stuff uh forget
it and a little pillow for him to rest
his little head a thank you for that now
let's see here sorry for all the tape
Read Me Maybe dearest
Mark I'm one of your biggest fans I made
this for you I hope you like him he took
a lot of time and effort to make I've
watched all your videos and I keep up
with them daily oh and yes that other
thing in the package is a pillow for him
also handmade I love what you're doing
with your channel I try to donate at
your charity live streams and share all
your videos you deserve to have more
followers I'm trying not to make this
letter too long I know how busy you are
let me summ it all up keep doing what
you're doing you're an inspiration to
myself and others as well you've changed
my life for the better I love you you
know what I mean not in love but love as
a friendly Friendship feeling meaning
okay bye love Holly you're so handsome
and smart and strong winky face thank
you so much all right we are
done
yay
huh what oh
okay ah thank you guys so
much woo boy all right I'm I'm like
really
tired it's been a long day and I still
got a lot to go so thank you guys so
much for being here with me hope you
enjoyed it remember there are only two
more mail videos left so if you want
your stuff into me on camera got to get
it in soon cuz there's not much time
left two weeks is plenty of time to get
it into me but after next week you're
going to have to rush so thank you guys
so much for watching thank you guys for
the support thank you for sending me the
awesome stuff I really love it you guys
are the best oh man don't leave make a
gift what can I make what can what else
can I
do
make this a gift my
sorrow I got to be
close the feels put feels like feels up
here in big blinking
feels
okay all right so thank you guys so much
for watching don't click annotations cuz
they're not there and as as always I
will see
you from the ne in the next in in the
next video byebye bye bye everybody bye
bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye